artificial intelligence is attempting is
our current human attempt to use
non-quantum classical physics to mimic
our brains and our intelligence and our
Consciousness right and we're seeing
that that problem is almost intractable
it is remarkably complicated we know the
steps but the hardware is seemingly
insurmountable the insurmountable
complications of the human mind might
not be what you'd want to emulate at all
you want to emulate the parts of the
human mind that are capable of good
things and and and accurate things so
it's easy to praise the brain because we
don't understand it rather than ask does
the brain do things that we don't need
to emulate at all because we can do it
better by other means if we put an AI on
the problem of solving climate change
okay it might be able to solve it in a
day but how would you solve it by
killing every human being so that we
don't have to create any more carbon